giulia chessmen started her career more
than 30 years ago as a script reader she
made her marques producer of independent
films like quills the Paris family and
25th hour years later she finds she she
finds that her job remains essentially
the same reading and evaluating scripts
this is her fourth year on the nickel
Executive Committee presenting the award
to Sarah Jane and words is Julia chasman
[Applause]
I'm gonna go like this when Jen was up
here I saw how short I was gonna look
behind this podium so I'm gonna go like
this I want to tell you a little bit
about Sarah Jane in words and I hope I
don't embarrass her Sarah Jane had a
relatively normal childhood
in Rochester Minnesota but in her
teenage years she had to undergo a
series of difficult abdominal surgeries
threatening her chance for living a
normal and healthy life she battled
depression during this period also
fearing for the future but the heroic
medical interventions of doctors at the
Mayo Clinic gave her back her life and
gave her the grateful inspiration to pay
it forward besides becoming an active
volunteer at the make-a-wish Foundation
she started her own charity co-founding
the applause for a cause student
organization at Northwestern University
where she was studying film writing this
organization now in its eighth year
continues to raise thousands of dollars
for charity each year but these
activities are more than just sidelines
to her creative work Sarah Jane puts her
ideals into her writing creating stories
that inspire compassion and deal with
issues of social and social justice
her nickel winning screenplay jellyfish
summer tackles today's all-too-familiar
problems of refugees and migrants
through a unique lens combining a
child's point of view in the mid 1960s
with an allegory inspired by ideas from
science fiction it is an unexpected and
surprisingly moving tale full of
surprises at the age of 26 Sarah Jane
has a stunning future ahead of her and
it gives me great pleasure to introduce
her to you tonight and to present her
with this well-earned fellowship Sarah
Jane
[Applause]
Wow Thank You Juliet so much that was
sweet thank you and thank you to our
actors and to Roderigo Daffy for putting
on this live read it is incredible in
such a treat for all of us so thank you
very much for your time thank you
you know the scene that you just saw is
one that's very close to my heart where
Macy's mother is teaching her about the
importance of helping others this is a
lesson that I was taught by my parents
who are here tonight Carrie and David
Edwards I was taught this lesson by both
of them not only did they tell me
verbally how important it is to help
others but they demonstrated in their
lives every day
they have both dedicated their lives to
helping others as physicians that work
with cancer patients and as you heard
Julia say I'm personally have benefited
so much from the work of doctors so when
I looked at my career my ambitions I
thought oh right how am I going to help
others with what I want to do which is
to make movies and I have to say I felt
a little bit intimidated comparing
myself to people who literally save
lives so when I brought this quandary to
my dad who's sitting up there tonight I
said how you know how am I supposed to
compare myself to what you do how am I
supposed to help others and he gave me a
bit of advice that really stuck with me
to this day he said some people save
lives
some people make them worth living so um
yeah so I think that's what all of us
here are trying to do when we make films
we're trying to make what life worth
living whether that's by providing some
entertainment a laugh a shared
experience or maybe it's by advocating
for a cause or representing someone so
that they can sit in a seat and look up
at the screen and see someone just like
them accomplishing great things so I
just really want to thank the Academy
Joan Greg everybody who put in their
time to this fellowship to give us the
opportunity to do just that this next
year I am grateful beyond words for that
I'd like to thank all of my family for
my mom and dad and brother who are here
tonight I'd like to thank my boyfriend
Kenny I love you I'd like to thank all
of my friends especially aleksef Kylee
Schmidt Kelly Martin all of my friends
here tonight I'd like to thank my
managers at Kaplan Peron and I'd like to
give a shout out to applause for a cause
which you heard about at Northwestern
University and finally I'd like to
dedicate this award to my grandma Glenda
I miss you and I love you thank you
[Applause]